et 2021 pour vous entretenir
une nouvelle fois avec le ministre des
solidarités de la santé de la crise
sanitaire qui dure depuis maintenant dix
mois
c'est aussi pour moi l'occasion de
présenter à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous mes voeux les plus sincères pour
cette année nouvelle
avec évidemment une pensée toute
particulière pour toutes celles et ceux
qui ont subi les affres de cette
pandémie
les familles et les proches de ceux qui
en sont morts celles et ceux qui ont été
malades parfois gravement et le très
grand nombre d'entre vous qui avaient
été affectées directement ou
indirectement dans votre emploi dans
votre activité dans votre vie
quotidienne familiale ou sociale dans
votre équilibre personnel c'est à dire
quasiment la nation tout entière un
moment très difficile de notre histoire
dont j'ai une conscience aiguë des
situations parfois dramatiques
auxquelles nous devons faire face avec
courage avec détermination et avec
humanité 2021 sera l'année de
l'espérance notamment grâce à la
campagne de vaccination sur laquelle
nous reviendrons longuement mais il me
faut préalablement vous présenter la
situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui de notre pays même si le
virus circule légèrement moins en france
que chez la plupart de nos voisins
la situation est loin d'être revenue à
la normale le niveau des contaminations
dans notre pays reste élevé il a même
tendance à progresser depuis la mi
décembre nous étions alors à en moyenne
à 10 me de contamination par jour
nous sommes aujourd'hui un peu au dessus
des 15 mille cas quotidiens soit trois
fois plus que l'objectif vous en
souvenez de 5000 cas par jour que nous
nous étions fixés
certes c'est beaucoup moins que les 50
mille quatre par jour que nous avions
enregistré fin octobre au moment du
deuxième confinement certes la
circulation du virus reste moins active
chez nous
que dans la plupart de nos voisins
européens ou les mesures de confinement
ont été renforcées ces dernières
semaines et même ces derniers jours au
royaume uni le nombre de nouveaux cas
explose depuis quelques semaines avec un
taux d'incidence près de huit fois
supérieur au nôtre
les poussant au confinement total
jusqu'en mars la suisse qui avait été
peu frappée par la première vague un
taux d'incidence et un taux de mortalité
deux fois supérieur au nôtre
l'allemagne qui a un taux de positivité
des tests près de deux fois supérieure à
la france a dû se résoudre à un
confinement pour casser cette courbe
notre situation actuelle est sans doute
la conséquence des mesures de
confinement que nous avons prises au bon
moment dès la fin octobre et qui ont eu
un réel impact avec le couvre-feu cela
tient certainement aussi au sens des
responsabilités dont nous avons fait
collectivement preuve au moment des
fêtes de fin d'année ce n'est toutefois
que la semaine prochaine que nous aurons
suffisamment de recul pour apprécier les
effets et nous resterons très attentifs
à l'évolution dans les jours à venir car
je le disais la situation sanitaire de
notre pays n'est pas revenue à la
normale
elle est même devenue plus fragile au
cours des dernières semaines
nous observons ainsi une pression sur
notre système hospitalier qui reste très
forte
chaque jour nous enregistrons près de
deux mille cinq cents nouvelles
hospitalisations et plus de 200
admission en réanimation
soit une personne toutes les 7 minutes
et cette pression ne s'est pas réduite
au cours du dernier mois nous sommes
toujours à plus de 25000 personnes
hospitalisées dont 2600 malades en
réanimation un lit de réanimation sur
deux est occupé par un malade de l'aco
vide pour les accueillir
nous devons faire de la place en
continuant à des programmes et des
opérations chirurgicales moins d'urgence
il est donc hors de question de désarmer
notre système hospitalier
nous constatons également que la
situation se dégrade dans certains
territoires plus rapidement qu'ailleurs
c'est le cas dans les régions situées à
l'est du pays ce qui nous a conduits à
prendre dans la semaine dernière des
mesures spécifiques dans 15 départements
c'est aussi le cas de certains
territoires d'outre-mer notamment la
guyane à cela s'ajoute l'inquiétude liée
à l'évolution de la situation au royaume
uni la flambée de cas que connaît ce
pays et dont je vous parlais à l'instant
pourrait être dû à l'apparition d'une
souche variante du virus
un autre est également apparu en afrique
du sud
si ces nouvelles souches virales semble
être encore peu répandue dans notre pays
elle pourrait selon les connaissances
scientifiques encore préliminaires dont
nous disposons être davantage
contagieuse compte tenu de ces éléments
et du degré d'incertitude encore élevé
nous avons immédiatement réagi pour
empêcher le plus possible que ces virus
depuis se propager sur notre territoire
nous avons décidé le 20 décembre dernier
de fermer les frontières avec le royaume
uni et cette mesure sera prolongée
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
seules certaines catégories de personnes
très précises sont autorisées elles
doivent obligatoirement présenter un
test négatif réalisés sur le territoire
britannique pour rentrer sur notre
territoire
je cède la parole au ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand qui va vous
présenter des informations qui sont à
notre disposition sur ces deux souches
virales
effectivement monsieur le premier
ministre si un virus comme le colis de
19 est amené à muter régulièrement
deux variantes ce virus issu de mutation
repéré au royaume uni et en afrique du
sud nous inquiète et on immobilise en
particulier le variant sud africain est
encore mal connue il fait l'objet de
recherches à l'échelle mondiale nos
techniques de génétiques ont permis à ce
jour de le repérer chez trois patients
sur le territoire national le variant
anglais lui fait l'objet de davantage
d'études connu et de publication est ce
que nous savons nous suspectons à date
sur ce variant anglais je vais le résumé
d'abord il est considéré comme plus
contagieux de l'ordre de 40 jusqu'à 70%
plus contagieux que le variant que nous
connaissons en france
deuxièmement en environ deux mois il est
devenu le variant majoritaire en
angleterre c'est à dire qu'il a pris la
place du variant tels que l'angleterre
ne connaissait et qui est le variant
actuellement diffusion en france
troisièmement parce qu'il est plus
contagieux il est responsable d'une
aggravation importante de l'épidémie en
angleterre je rappelle par ailleurs que
l'angleterre comme l'ecosse ont décidé
d'un nouveau confinement
quatrièmement il donnerait le même type
de symptômes que le variant classique
sans davantage de cas graves
mais comme il est plus contagieux
forcément les cas symptomatiques et donc
les cas graves sont également plus
nombreux cinquièmement il serait plus
contagieux également chez les enfants
après certaines études préliminaires
mais ne serait pas plus grave chez
l'enfant que le virus que nous
connaissons fort heureusement
nous voulons éviter à tout prix la
diffusion de ce variant en france à ce
jour nous avons identifié 19 cas en
circulation sur le territoire national
dont deux dans le cadre de clusters dits
à risque un en ile de france est un
en bretagne nous nous attendons
clairement à en identifier davantage
voici ce que nous mettons en place pour
pouvoir être particulièrement vigilants
et actifs
d'abord tous les laboratoires mais aussi
des centres de recherche et bien sûr
santé publique france sont mobilisés
pour traquer le variante partout ce
jeudi et demain tous les tests pcr
douteuse c'est à dire pouvant suggérer
qu'il s'agit d'un cas de variants
anglais seront analysés sur nos
plateformes pour ce qu'on appelle du
séquençage génétique permettant de
dénombrer le nombre précis de cas de
variants à date sur le territoire
national pour la journée donc
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
deuxièmement une surveillance accrue est
organisé dans les écoles en lien avec
jean michel blanquer ainsi que des
opérations de dépistage
troisièmement toute personne venant de
grande-bretagne mais également d'afrique
du sud doit présenter le résultat d'un
test négatif datant de moins de 72
heures avant le départ
s'ils souhaitent venir en france nous
prenons la menace de ce variant anglais
et la menace de ce variant sud africain
très au sérieux et nous prendrons toutes
les mesures qui s'imposeront si ces
variants devait s'avérer diffusé sur le
territoire national merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
face à cette situation donc fragile il
n'est donc pas question que nous
baissions lagarde dans les semaines à
venir nous devons non seulement
maintenir les mesures en vigueur visant
à freiner la circulation du virus mètres
près je le dis à les renforcer
dès l'instant où cela s'avérait
nécessaire en fonction de l'évolution
des prochains jours et des prochaines
semaines
la situation relativement maîtrisée de
l'épidémie en france ne doit en effet
pas nous induire en erreur la deuxième
vague est toujours là nous sommes loin
de l'objectif des 5000 cas par jour qui
correspond au seuil de maîtrise de
l'épidémie
la pression sur notre système de santé
restent élevés et nous ne sommes
toujours pas sorti d'affaires nous
devons retrouver une dynamique de baisse
c'est la condition pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'epide et pour y parvenir
cela me conduit à arrêter les
dispositions suivantes premièrement
toutes les activités tous les
établissements tous les équipements qui
sont aujourd'hui fermées et le resteront
encore jusqu'à la fin de ce mois les
musées les cinémas les théâtres les
salles de spectacle les équipements
sportifs ou de loisirs ne connaîtront
dans les semaines qui viennent
aucun assouplissement nous avions fixé
s'agissant du secteur de la culture avec
roselyne bachelot un point de revoyure
début janvier la situation sanitaire que
je viens de vous décrire ne nous permet
malheureusement aucune évolution
aujourd'hui les conditions d'une reprise
à compter de début février seront ainsi
concerter avec les représentants de ces
secteurs que j'ai rencontré à la fin
d'année dernière
nous souhaitons leur donner de la
visibilité en travaillant avec eux à
l'élaboration d'une méthode d'ouverture
encadré et progressive nous ferons un
point le 20 janvier prochain afin
d'examiner alors en fonction de la
situation sanitaire
s'il est possible de confirmer la
possibilité et les conditions d'une
reprise d'activité à partir de début
février
nous avons conscience qu'à situation est
aujourd'hui très difficile pour les
artistes et les professionnels de la
culture et la ministre est totalement
engagé et déterminé à leurs côtés il en
va de même du secteur sportif que nous
accompagnons fortement avec les
ministres concernés les mêmes
considérations me conduisent à prendre
la même décision pour les stations de
ski dans les remontées mécaniques ne
pourront pas rouvrir tout de suite je
comprends là encore l'inquiétude des
élus
et professionnels de la montagne je sais
combien ils ont besoin de visibilité
notamment sur la possibilité d'ouvrir
pendant les vacances de février
c'est vital pour ces territoires pour
lesquels cette activité saisonnière fait
vivre des familles entières toute
l'année c'est un objectif que nous
pouvons nous fixer mais il serait
prématuré de prendre une décision
aujourd'hui compte tenu des incertitudes
sanitaires qui demeure là encore nous
ferons un point le 20 janvier
à deux semaines du début des vacances
scolaires
l'état continuera donc d'accompagner les
acteurs économiques et des territoires
de montagne
il poursuivra également son action
diplomatique vis-à-vis des pays voisins
dotés de stations de sports d'hiver
nous ferons également ce point de
situation avec les restaurateurs des
propriétaires de bars et les salles de
sport pour qui malheureusement la
perspective d'une réouverture en janvier
n'est pas réaliste et sera d'ores et
déjà reporté à minima jusqu'à mi-février
bien évidemment pendant toute cette
période de fermeture ou d'activité
limitée le gouvernement continuera à
soutenir économiquement l'ensemble des
secteurs et les acteurs qui sont
impactées directement par nos mesures
qu'il s'agisse du recours à l'activité
partielle aux prêts garantis au fonds de
solidarité rénové aux différentes aides
sectorielles tous nos dispositifs seront
maintenus dans les mêmes conditions et
les ministres compétents seront chargés
de rencontrer les filières concernées
pour examiner d'éventuels besoins
d'accompagnement complémentaires
notamment pour ceux des secteurs qui
sont fermés sur une très longue durée
pour les aides au titre du mois de
décembre le formulaire sera mis en ligne
sur le site impots.gouv.fr dès le 15
janvier jusqu'au 20 janvier également
nous prolongeant le régime de couvre feu
à 20 heures depuis samedi dernier je le
disais tout à l'heure il a été avancé à
18h dans 15 départements où nous avons
observé une reprise particulièrement
sensible de la circulation virale avec
un taux d'incidence de plus de 200 cas
pour 100000 habitants
cette mesure s'appliquera au moins 15
jours
les derniers chiffres nous amène à
identifier dix départements
supplémentaires plutôt situés dans l'est
de la france où pourraient également se
poser la question d'une mise en oeuvre
de ce couvre-feu avancé comme nous
l'avons fait la semaine dernière les
préfets vont conduire très rapidement
les concertations nécessaires avec les
élus de ces territoires
pour bien analyser la situation et en
fonction de leur retour des décisions
seront prises d'ici demain soir pour
entrer en vigueur à compter de dimanche
l'ensemble des dispositions que je viens
d'énoncer sont nécessaires mais je ne
peux exclure que nous ayons à prendre
des mesures nationales supplémentaires
si nous faisons le constat dans les
prochains jours que nous en avons besoin
je souhaite évidemment que nous
puissions l'éviter mais comme beaucoup
de pays qui viennent de prendre de
telles mesures récemment nous devrons
réagir vite
si nous faisons le constat d'une
nouvelle accélération du virus ainsi la
forte présence de l'épidémie les
conditions climatiques actuelles et à
venir nous rappellent que malgré les
perspectives de la vaccination
nous ne devons pas baisser la garde nous
devons maintenir des mesures de freinage
continuer à toujours respecter les
mesures barrières
nous devons également poursuivre et
renforcer notre stratégie tester alerté
protéger nous avons aujourd'hui en
france un dispositif de dépistage
particulièrement développée je vous
rappelle qu'il repose sur la gratuité
les tests sont totalement gratuits en
france pour tout le monde
cet unique en europe pour une personne
asymptomatiques souhaitant se faire
tester
il faut ainsi débourser près de 100
euros en allemagne ou en espagne jusqu'à
350 euros royaume uni et même être tiré
au sort en grèce en france chacun peut
se faire tester à côté de chez lui dans
son laboratoire g100 pharmaciens chez
son médecin dans un cabinet infirmier
même chez son dentiste
on compte plus de 12000 points de tests
en france
notre dispositif était calibré en mai
dernier pour sept cent mille tests par
semaine nous l'avons porté à 1 millions
par semaine en septembre 2 millions en
novembre et pendant la semaine précédant
noël
nous avons réalisé trois millions et
demi de tests sans augmentation des
délais d'attentes
c'est plus que tout autre pays en europe
depuis mais nous n'avons pas eu de cesse
d'optimiser notre politique de dépistage
afin d'améliorer le délai de prise de
rendez vous et de rendu des tests nous
n'avons jamais caché nos difficultés en
septembre dernier lorsque les délais se
sont allongées sous l'effet de
l'accélération de la demande
nous les avons précisément identifiés y
avons apporté les réponses de telle
sorte qu'aujourd'hui 86% les résultats
sont rendus à moins de 24 heures c'est
une réussite dont nous pouvons être
fiers et je salue toutes les personnes
qui y contribuent au quotidien
d'autres améliorations sont nécessaires
pour gagner en efficacité et mieux
garantir l'effectivité de l' isolement
des personnes positives et de leurs cas
contacts cela passera par des outils et
des moyens nouveaux
à partir du 10 janvier dès que vous avez
des symptômes ou que vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter il vous suffira de vous
inscrire sur le site de l'assurance
maladie pour obtenir un arrêt de travail
immédiat indemnisé sans jour de carence
lassègue l'assurance-maladie procédera à
un suivi systématique avec deux à trois
appels téléphoniques sur sept jours
chaque personne déclarée positive se
verra proposer à compter du 20 janvier
une vie
it à domicile par un infirmier mais nous
pouvons désormais compter sur une arme
encore plus puissante
le vaccin qui constitue notre principale
source d'espoir pour sortir de cette
crise la campagne vaccinale contre la
corrida commencé le 27 décembre dernier
va se poursuivre dans les mois à venir
elle suscite des attentes qui sont
légitimes mais aussi des interrogations
qui le sont tout autant
en revanche elle a donné lieu ces
derniers jours de la part de certains à
des propos et des critiques parfois
outrancier oui c'est vrai notre prof de
vaccination a démarré plus lentement que
dans d'autres pays ce décalage
s'explique par notre choix de respecter
les principes et de priorités qui nous
ont été fixées par la haute autorité de
santé
ces principes de ce calendrier ses
priorités avaient été annoncées partager
concerter avec les professionnels de
santé avec des associations d'élus au
cours de nombreuses réunions y compris à
mon niveau
ils vous avaient été présentés ici même
le 2 décembre dernier ils ont été
détaillées devant le parlement les 15 et
16 décembre
je souhaite vous en rappeler les
fondements et les objectifs vous
présenter aussi l'organisation que nous
avons retenu pour un assuré le
déploiement mais aussi les dispositions
que nous avons prises pour accélérer la
mise en oeuvre car oui en effet comme
l'a souhaité le président de la
république nous devons gagner du temps
et aller plus vite
premier principe tous ceux qui le
souhaitent doivent pouvoir accéder aux
vaccins
le faire sur la base du volontariat
évidemment de manière gratuite et dans
le respect de garanties strictes en
matière de recueil du consentement et de
surveillance des éventuels effets
indésirables
deuxième élément clé pour répondre à cet
engagement
la france a pré commandé plus de 200
millions de vaccins qui nous seront
livrés tout au long de l'année
12h21 je vous rappelle que nous avons
avec nos partenaires européens pré
commander depuis juin dernier
tous les vaccins les plus prometteurs et
je veux être clair que c'était le seul
mécanisme de nature à garantir le plus
grand nombre de doses pour nos
concitoyens
au vu de la saturation actuelle du
marché il nous a déjà permis de
constituer un portefeuille très large de
vaccins en cours de développement nous
en avons même commandé beaucoup plus que
nécessaire pourquoi car il est possible
que certains de ces vaccins n'obtiennent
pas les autorisations ou les obtiennent
plus tard qu'annoncé
cela ne dépend pas de nous et nous avons
donc pris des marges de sécurité pour ne
pas être en pénurie
la ministre en charge du dossier agnès
pannier rue nash et pourra tout à leur
répondre à vos questions sur ce sujet
pour autant cela signifie que tout le
monde ne pourra pas être vaccinés tout
de suite en france comme ailleurs
notre objectif est donc clair et il a
toujours été vaccinées en priorité le
plus vite possible les 15 millions de
personnes âgées et souffrant de
pathologies chroniques
pourquoi eux parce que les premiers
vaccins qui arrive permettent surtout de
prévenir quand on attrape la convient de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
cela veut donc dire qu'il faut protéger
celles et ceux qui sont les plus à
risque d'être hospitalisé voire de
décennies
c'est à dire les 15 millions de
personnes âgées ou atteintes d'une
pathologie chronique
si nous parvenons à vacciner ces 15
millions de personnes nous les aurons
protéger du risque sanitaire et nous
aurons protéger nos hôpitaux
nous avons bon espoir que d'autres
vaccins obtiennent dans les semaines à
venir les autorisations nécessaires pour
que nous puissions bénéficier de
davantage de doses et donc davezac
signer davantage de personnes encore
d'ici l'été
après court terme d'ici fin janvier les
quantités reçues et qui arrive au cours
du mois nous permettant d'être en
capacité de vacciner au moins un million
de personnes soit le même nom
ambre que nos voisins européens au
prorata de notre population
ce rythme est celui des capacités
industrielles qui sont aujourd'hui en
forte tension
nous veillerons à acheminer des doses de
vaccin sur l'ensemble du territoire
national y compris dans les départements
d'outre-mer troisième élément clé la
haute autorité de santé nous a demandé
de démarrer la vaccination par les
personnes un ehpad et en unités de soins
de longue durée car ce sont elles qui
ont payé le plus lourd tribut à la crise
si elle ne représente que 1% de la
population
elles représentent un tiers des morts de
la crise même si cela est plus long même
si cela est plus difficile d'aller
vacciner ces personnes et que cela ne
permet pas immédiatement de faire du
chiffre il est indispensable de le faire
cette première phase est également
ouverte aux personnes en situation de
handicap vulnérables qui sont hébergées
en maison d'accueil spécialisée et en
foyer d'accueil médicalisé
c'est un impératif sanitaire et c'est un
impératif éthique et ce choix des ehpad
explique très largement le démarrage
très progressif des premiers jours
chacun peut en effet entendre qu'on ne
recueille pas le consentement d'une
personne de 90 ans atteinte de la
maladie d'alzheimer comme on le ferait
pour un jeune de 20 ans nous voulons
faire les choses bien dans le respect de
ces personnes en présence de leur
médecin traitant avec l'accord de leurs
familles ce sont les directeurs d'ehpad
des professionnels de santé des
associations de patients qui nous ont
demandé de leur laisser le temps
d'organiser cela les vaccinations à
nepad ont démarré depuis le 27 décembre
et s'accéléreront comme prévu dans les
prochains jours jusqu'à fin janvier
début février
j'ai demandé à madame lasserre qui est
directrice de nepad à paris de venir
nous présenter vous présentez vous
expliquer la manière dont se passe
concrètement la préparation de nepad à
la vaccination
merci madame
monsieur le premier ministre merci de me
donner la parole je suis devant vous en
qualité de directrice d'un ehpad qui
accueille 94 personnes en grande
majorité des personnes âgées vulnérables
en perte d'autonomie polypathologiques
est pour beaucoup atteints de maladies
neuro évolutive et je viens vous faire
partager mon expérience de terrain
comme beaucoup d'autres établissements
notre établissement et est fortement
touchée lors de la première vague du coc
vide un tiers de nos résidents ont été
atteints en sont décédés et 23
collaborateurs ont été infectées et je
tiens ici à rendent hommage à toutes les
familles qui ont été frappés par cette
pandémie depuis près d'un an nous avons
lutté avec tous les moyens dont nous
disposions modifier les protocoles et
adapter notre organisation afin de
limiter au maximum l'impact du virus et
l'arrivée de ce vaccin est une vraie
source d'espoir pour tous nos résidents
pour leurs proches et pour toutes nos
équipes depuis le 23 décembre date de la
publication de l'avis de la chasse nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés pour mettre
en oeuvre la vaccination
conformément à la stratégie définie par
le gouvernement avec l'appui des
services supports pour ma part de de mon
groupe à cppa nous avons établi des
liens et des communications régulières
avec les résidents les familles et les
représentants légaux qui ont permis de
recenser les 20 premiers volontaires
dans mon ehpad en lien avec notre
médecin coordonnateur les médecins
traitants se sont mobilisés pour
réaliser les visites près vaccinale
recueillir les consentements et lorsque
cela était nécessaire prendre l'avis des
proches ou des représentants légaux sans
cadre formel mais le médecin faisant le
lien avec le dossier médical de son
patient cette première phase fait des
changes et d'information est essentielle
et nous y consacrons tous temps
nécessaire elle se déroule dans le
respect des personnes que nous
accueillons celui de leurs droits et
selon le principe déontologique du libre
choix
cette temporalité nous permet de mener
cette campagne dans un climat empreint
de confiance et de sérénité en amont
s'étend des changes
résidents familles et soignants s'avère
important et très positif et je peux
témoigner que souvent ils permettent de
lever les doutes et d'évacuer les
inquiétudes ainsi une de nos résidentes
par exemple était totalement
réfractaires à la vaccination dans un
premier temps elle s'y rallie après un
cheminement au cours duquel elle a pu
poser toutes les questions nécessaires à
une prise de décision éclairée
elle a également pu partager du ce temps
de réflexion avec sa famille sur ce
point il est à noter que beaucoup de
familles nous contactent spontanément
par téléphone ou par courriel pour mieux
s'informer et pour nous faire part de
leurs souhaits en lien avec l'agencé
régionale de santé et l'ap-hp
l'acheminement des doses de vaccin sera
organisée avec la coopération de notre
pharmacien d'officine de ville ce qui
permet de garantir le strict respect des
protocoles et de la chaîne du froid
de même comme dans cette première phase
pilote non résidents qui le souhaitent
seront vaccinés par groupes de cinq
ils bénéficieront d'une surveillance
rapprochée pendant une trentaine de
minutes autour d'un papotage et dans un
esprit de convivialité néanmoins et
compte tenu de la fragilité plus grande
de certains l'équipe médicale et
paramédicale restera vigilante et
assurera un accompagnement ainsi qu une
attention renforcée pendant 48 heures à
ce jour les 20 premiers résidents qui
ont été vaccinés lors de la première
phase pilote le 30 décembre dernier se
porte parfaitement bien
tous ont exprimé leur satisfaction du
déroulé de l'événement ainsi que des
modalités de suivi
ils sont désormais nos meilleurs
ambassadeurs leurs témoignages
rassurants ont été de nature à
encourager le passage à l'acte de
nombreux de nos co résidents et
aujourd'hui trente résidants déjà passé
une visite médicale et ont fait part de
leur souhait de recevoir ce vaccin
le 18 janvier prochain par ailleurs nos
collaborateurs sont également de plus en
plus nombreux à avoir donné leur accord
comme les 700 les 7000 autres et pas de
france on va poursuivre cette campagne
qui pour nous être porteuse vraiment de
tant d'espoirs et nous sommes prêts
merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup madame comment comme le
président de la république nous l'a
demandé à aller encore plus vite
il ne s'agit pas de modifier comme je
lai entendu ici ou là notre stratégie
mais il s'agit par tous moyens
d'anticiper d'optimiser de simplifier sa
mise en oeuvre et son déploiement
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'avancer ce que nous appelons la phase
2 de notre stratégie vaccinale
après les ehpad qui ne devait démarrer
qu'en février et cela dans trois
directions première évolution les
professionnels de santé et les aides à
domicile de plus de 50 ans peuvent se
faire vacciner depuis lundi au total ce
sont déjà plus de 45000 personnes qui
ont été vaccinées au cours des cinq
derniers jours
deuxième évolution les personnes de plus
de 75 ans pourront se faire vacciner à
partir de lundi 18 janvier ces
vaccinations se dérouleront dans des
centres de vaccination un centre par
département a déjà été ouverts donc sans
sur le territoire à partir de lundi
prochain
il y en aura trois cents puis six ans
progressivement jusqu'à la fin du mois
de janvier
j'ai par ailleurs décidé que le
déploiement de la stratégie vaccinale
dans les territoires s'effectuera selon
les principes suivants les directeurs
généraux des ars les préfets de région
sont les garants du déploiement de la
stratégie vaccinale de sa transparence
et du respect de ses règles éthiques
les préfets de département avec l'appui
des délégués territoriaux de la rs
seront les patrons un pilote par
département des opérations logistiques
de vaccination ils impliqueront le
maximum de professionnels de santé dans
le cadre des structures existantes
médecins infirmiers pharmaciens que ces
derniers soient libéraux un
établissement avec mobilisation possible
des retraités ils travailleront avec les
élus locaux les maires en particulier
parce que c'est un sujet de proximité et
les présidents d'agglomération en sièges
des centres de vaccination
tous ces élus qui ont et je les en
remercie pour beaucoup fait d'ores et
déjà acte de candidature pour contribuer
à cette formidable opération évidemment
les organisations retenues pour en
varier selon les départements et les
territoires je fais confiance aux
acteurs des territoires
parallèlement nous simplifiant les
démarches les différentes étapes qui
avait été prévu pour les personnes très
vulnérables
un ehpad et que vous a rappelé madame la
directrice et en décembre quand nous
avions encore peu de recul sur le vaccin
seront allégées pour les populations
moins fragiles ou se faire vacciner
comment prendre rendez vous quelles sont
les démarches à entreprendre
le ministre de la santé va maintenant
vous donner davantage de précisions
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour vous
permettre de vous faire vacciner dans de
bonnes conditions
il ya 48 heures j'ai annoncé que nous
disposions désormais de suffisamment de
garanties retour d'expérience mais aussi
recommandations pour pouvoir amplifier
accélérer et simplifier notre stratégie
vaccinale les retours d'expérience ce
sont ces millions d'humains désormais
vaccinés de par le monde
le vaccin est sûr les effets
indésirables graves sont extrêmement
rares on nous dit d'après les premières
remontées mais qui sont consolidées jour
après jour de l'ordre d'environ un
patient pour cent mille vacciner ce sont
des événements de nature essentiellement
allergiques et qui interviennent chez
des personnes qui sont par ailleurs
connu pour être très allergique même
sans contexte de vaccination au point
que le plus souvent elles ne sortent pas
de chez elle sans avoir un kit et
d'adrénaline sur elle les garanties ce
sont les circuits logistiques qui ont
montré qu'ils étaient pleinement
opérationnel et qui font que dans chaque
département des vaccins ont été ou sont
livrés les recommandations ce sont les
autorités scientifiques et sanitaires
qui nous disent que nous pouvons
anticiper la vaccination des publics
prioritaires au delà des seuls résidents
âgées en établissement collectif
après 48 heures voici donc nos premiers
résultats
je disais amplifiés et accélérés nous
avons accéléré le rythme de livraison de
nombreux ehpad dans de nombreux
territoires
nous avons initié la vaccination des
soignants des pompiers des aides à
domicile âgé de 50 ans et plus ou
porteurs de ce qu'on appelle les
comorbidités c'est à dire des maladies
qui les expose à des risques de forme
grave
nous ouvrons également avec sophie
cluzel la vaccination aux personnes
handicapées qui vivent en établissements
spécialisés mais aussi aux personnels
qui y travaillent s'ils sont âgés de 50
ans ou plus ou s'ils ont eux mêmes
porteurs de comorbidité ensuite nous
avons multiplié par près de quatre le
nombre d'hôpitaux libre et en vaccins
nous avons ouvert au moins un centre de
vaccination par département et même
plusieurs centres dans bon nombre de
départements
monsieur le premier ministre vous l'avez
dit nous avons permis la vaccination
avant-hier d'environ 5000 personnes il
hier c'était 12 mille cinq cents
personnes nous n'avons pas les chiffres
définitifs du jour
mais ce sera au moins 25000 personnes
supplémentaires vacciner aujourd'hui
avec une montée en puissance qui va se
poursuivre jour après jour jusqu'à
atteindre ce rythme de croisière que
nous voulons de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de français vaccinés par jour
et nous visons un million de personnes
vaccinées d'ici à la fin du mois de
janvier
c'est bien c'est mieux mais vous l'avez
dit monsieur le premier ministre nous
souhaitons aller plus loin plus fort et
plus vite les autorités sanitaires
françaises viennent de valider un
principe important selon lequel il est
possible sans risque et sans perte
d'efficacité de différer la deuxième
injection du vaccin de pfizer ce qu'on
appelle un rappel vaccinal jusqu'à six
semaines au lieu de trois cela nous
permet de disposer de davantage de doses
disponibles tout de suite en tout ce
sont 1 millions 46 mille doses de vaccin
riser dont nous disposons actuellement -
celle dont qui ont été injectés et
chaque semaine nous recevrons 500 mille
doses supplémentaires de ce vaccin et ce
jusqu'à la fin du mois de février
en mars le rythme doublera environ un
million de vaccins livrés par semaine
grâce à l'ouverture de nouvelles lignes
de production
par ailleurs un autre vaccin à arn
messagers donc le même mécanisme que le
vaccin fader celui ci c'est moderna a
été autorisé dans les mêmes conditions
d'utilisation hier par l'agencé médicale
européenne du médicament et quelque
cinquante mille premiers vaccins seront
livrés dès lundi en tout nous attendons
un peu plus de 100000 vaccin pour le
mois de janvier pour modern à 500 milles
supplémentaires en février un peu plus
d'un million en mars et en avril et plus
de 2 millions en mai et en juin
enfin ce ne sont pas 1 2 3 mais si ça
entre de vaccination qui seront ouverts
en janvier dans chaque département
destiné à la population
c'est le choix de la proximité que nous
faisons pour les français raison
d'environ donc un centre pour 100000
habitants soit environ dix fois plus de
centres pour la population que nombre de
nos voisins comme par exemple nos
voisins allemands
le moment est donc venu de nous préparer
à élargir la liste des personnes pouvant
bénéficier de la vaccination je parle
des quelques 5 millions de français qui
sont âgés de 75 ans et plus
si vous êtes dans cette situation vous
pourrez à partir de la semaine prochaine
prendre rendez vous en vue d'être
vacciné et la vaccination pourra
commencer le 18 janvier prochain
je le dis tout de suite cette
vaccination elle sera nécessairement
progressive
elle prendra plusieurs semaines au fur
et à mesure chacun peut le comprendre
que les laboratoires nous fournirons les
doses de vaccin nous faisons en france
mais aussi à l'échelle européenne avec
agnès pannier runes haché avec clément
bonne le maximum pour sécuriser un
maximum de doses le monde entier dans la
même situation qui achètent les mêmes
vaccins et nous accompagnons les
entreprises y compris en europe
d'ailleurs pour augmenter les chaînes de
production
en pratique si vous avez 75 ans ou plus
donc qu'est ce qui va se passer
d'abord vous aurez deux moyens pour
prendre rendez vous pour vous faire
vacciner
il y aura un numéro de téléphone qui
sera communiqué prochainement qui vous
orientera vers les différents centres au
plus près de chez vous il y aura
également un site internet c'est le site
sante.fr qui vous indiquera la marche à
suivre pour vous signaler et prendre
rendez vous avec une carte interactive
où cliquer sur votre région vous avez la
liste des centres qui apparaît et vous
pourrez prendre rendez-vous d'ailleurs
directement sur ce site internet
nous voulons donner accès à cette ligne
téléphonique est au site internet jeudi
prochain 14 janvier
de moyens de prise de rendez-vous seront
progressivement enrichi à mesure que les
centres de vaccination seront ouverts en
supplémentaire est équipé en vaccins je
remercie d'ailleurs les ars les
préfectures les élus locaux les
soignants qui se mobilisent pour ouvrir
et faire fonctionner ces centres chaque
commune évidemment de notre territoire
national n'aura pas son propre centre ce
serait incohérent vu le nombre de doses
et de personnes à vacciner
la répartition départementale elle est
décidée en concertation avec les
services de l'état dans le cadre de
cellules territoriales amplifié accéléré
et je disais aussi simplifié j'y viens
mais d'abord je voudrais revenir sur un
certain nombre d'incompréhensions ou de
contre vérités qui ont pu circuler ces
derniers jours non il n'a jamais été
question d'exiger un consentement écrit
pour se faire vacciner
le consentement n'a pas plus de valeur
endroit que le consentement aura qu'ils
soient écrits ou qu'ils soient orale ce
qui est exigé
c'est qu'une personne qui va se faire
vacciner elle est reçue comme pour tout
acte médical une information claire
loyale et appropriée évidemment qu'il ne
se pose qu'elle ne s'oppose pas à la
vaccination
c'est par définition pas le cas d'une
personne âgée de 75 ans qui prendrait
rendez vous pour aller se faire vacciner
dans un centre mais pour une personne
âgée vulnérable et madame la directrice
d pad vous l'avez très bien dit tout à
l'heure qui n'est pas forcément capacité
d'exprimer dayan sa propre volonté
il faut s'assurer qu'elle ne s'y
opposent pas ou prendre le temps de
consulter la personne référente où la
famille non il n'a jamais été question
de recueillir un consentement cinq jours
avant de vacciner
ce que nous demandons aux ehpad c'est
d'indiquer le nombre de doses que nous
devons envoyer dans cet ehpad le jour j
imaginais une seconde qu'on envoie 100
doses de vaccins dans un ehpad où il ya
100 résidents et que le jour j de la
vaccination il n'eut que 40 personnes
qui acceptent ou qu'ils soient en état
de se faire vacciner
ce serait 60 doses de perdus et là ce
serait inexcusable
en pratique chaque ehpad connaît sa date
de livraison en vaccins et nous leur
demandons de faire remonter leurs
besoins précis quelques jours avant que
nous intervenions la vaccination en
ehpad a commencé progressivement elle va
prendre de l'ampleur
dès la semaine prochaine dans plusieurs
régions france entière à compter de la
semaine suivante est un délai qui
correspondait vous l'avez très bien dit
à la demande initiale des établissements
pour personnes âgées et nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué en charge de
l'autonomie en revanche le recul dont
nous disposons désormais nous permet
c'est vrai de simplifier le parcours de
la personne vaccinée sans rien renier
sur la sécurité et sur la qualité
le conseil d'orientation pour la
stratégie vaccinale qui est présidé par
le professeur alain fischer nous y
encourage voici donc en pratique comment
cela va se passer si vous avez 75 ans ou
plus vous êtes d'abord libre si vous le
souhaitez d'aller consulter votre
médecin pour lui poser toutes vos
questions vérifier l'absence de
contre-indication
mais ce n'est pas une obligation vous
pouvez le faire mais vous n'y êtes pas
obligé vous vous inscrivez donc par
téléphone ou sur le site sante.fr vous
réservez votre créneau dans le centre le
plus proche de chez vous sur place un
médecin ou toutes autres soignants
d'ailleurs vous posera quelques
questions on vous fera même remplir un
auto questionnaire très simple qui
visera juste à vérifier que vous pouvez
être vaccinés normalement et dans de
bonnes conditions quelques questions clé
résume avez vous une qu'ovide au cours
des trois derniers mois
avez vous été vaccinées contre la grippe
au cours des trois dernières semaines
souffrez-vous d'allergies graves
avez-vous de la fièvre ou d'autres
symptômes
prenez-vous certain traitement
particulier à signaler au cas où êtes
vous enceinte on est d'accord il ya peu
de risques après 75 ans mais je voudrais
être exhaustif
si vous le souhaitez vous pourrez voir
un médecin puisqu'il aura toujours un
médecin présent sur le centre court vous
serez vacciner sinon vous pouvez
directement passer à l'étape de la
vaccination c'est à dire qu'une fois le
questionnaire rempli et validé
médicalement vous serez invité à
recevoir l'injection du vaccin par un
médecin un infirmier ou d'ailleurs
toutes autres soignants habilité à le
faire
il s'agit d'une injection
intramusculaire dans l'épaule le plus
souvent comme la plupart des vaccins à
l'issue d'une injection vous serez amené
à rester environ 15 minutes sur place
par mesure de sécurité et ensuite vous
pourrez rentrer chez vous vous serez
vacciner il restera à faire la même
chose entre trois et six semaines après
la première injection et vous serez donc
protégé contre les formes graves du code
vide ce que je viens de décrire ce qui
va rythmer notre campagne de vaccination
au cours des deux prochains mois une
fois encore nous ferons le maximum pour
répondre au maximum de demandes le plus
vite possible
ensuite y'a une autre phase de la
vaccination ou plutôt deux autres phases
ailleurs qui démarreront d'abord
l'ouverture aux 65 ans et plus c'est à
dire 7 millions de français
supplémentaires c'est lorsque nous
aurons suffisamment protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles les plus
vulnérables dont les personnes âgées de
75 ans et plus et puis il y aura surtout
l'arrivée d'autres vaccins au
fonctionnement différent qui auront
évidemment eux aussi été validés parce
qu'ils seront jugés sûrs et efficaces
nous espérons ces vaccins avant le mois
de mars pour certains d'entre nous
disposerons de grandes quantités qui
permettront d'aller bien plus vite et de
protéger un maximum de français
ces vaccins et en plus ils ne sont pas
conservées à -80 degré ni à moins 20
degrés ils pourront être réalisés en
ville directement auprès de vos
soignants je rappelle à titre d'exemple
que cette année pour la campagne
grippale ce sont 1,5 million de doses de
vaccins contre la grippe qui ont été
écoulés en moins de 24 heures il m'est
difficile de fixer ici un nombre de
français qui seront vaccinées à coup sûr
avant l'été vous le comprendrez parce
que ça dépend de la validation en bonne
et due forme de ces vaccins et que nous
ne pouvons pas le savoir tant que ces
vaccins n'ont pas été validés mais je
vous confirme que en tout état de cause
nous avons commandé 78
lyon de doses qui sont normalement
livrés avant l'été entre les cinq
principaux vaccin c'est à dire les deux
qui existent déjà et les trois autres
dont nous espérons qu'ils le seront et
évidemment c'est suspendu au fait qu'il
soit validé chaque jour nous publierons
le nombre de vaccinations quotidiennes
et cumuler un système d'information
permet aux soignants de faire remonter
tous ces chiffres au quotidien il est
opérationnel depuis lundi il nécessite
encore quelques jours pour monter en
puissance vous comprendrez que quand on
demande aux soignants d'ouvrir des
centres de vaccination d'ouvrir des
lignes de vaccination de mobiliser les
soignants pour qu'ils se fassent
vacciner
il est compliqué d'exiger d'eux que tous
les jours à la bonne heure il fasse
remonter et les données mais ce sera le
cas très rapidement et vous aurez un
accès libre à ces informations et
évidemment pour leur demander aux
agences régionales de santé de nous
faire remonter chaque soir le nombre de
vaccinations qui ont été réalisés et ce
sont les chiffres que nous vous avons
communiqué avec le premier ministre pour
conclure j'ai conscience de l'impatience
légitime de ceux qui parmi vous ont hâte
de se faire vacciner
de tout ce qu'ils voient aussi dans le
vaccin une chance de reprendre le cours
normal de leur vie retrouver leur emploi
leur université leur salle de sport le
théâtre ce ne sont pas si jours qui font
une différence face à la pandémie
ni quelques dizaines de milliers de
vacciner ce qui fera la différence c'est
notre engagement collectif dans cette
reprise en main par l'homme d'un
environnement qui était devenu
défavorable
faites vous vacciner aidez vos proches à
se faire vacciner
réaliser la chance que la science nous
offre le moment que nous vivons est
historique il connaîtra ses eaux
peut-être ses bas ses grands moments
d'engouement collectif peut-être ces
phases incompréhension comme par exemple
nous devions manqué quelques jours de
vaccins entre deux ravitaillements mais
à la fin on nous vaccinons nous
sauveront des vies et nous retrouverons
la nôtre je le redis nous mettons tout
en oeuvre pour vous permettre de vous
faire vacciner dans de bonnes conditions
merci monsieur ministre de la santé vous
l'avez compris le déploiement de la
vaccination dessine une perspective
claire de pouvoir sortir progressivement
de cette crise sanitaire
à l'échéance nous l'espérons tous de
l'été prochain pour autant nous allons
devoir vivre avec ce virus encore
plusieurs mois
nous ne baisserons donc pas la garde sur
les gestes barrières les tests ou encore
les mesures de freinage ce serait
irresponsable
mais la vaccination est devenue la
priorité numéro 1 de l'action du
gouvernement
nous sommes tous convaincus que c'est la
vaccination la plus large la plus
massive et la plus rapide qui nous
permettra de sortir de la crise
ne confondons pas néamoins vitesse et
précipitation les choses doivent être
faites dans le plus grand sérieux et le
plus grand respect des personnes les
plus fragiles car nous avons besoin de
l'adhésion de tous
alors j'en appelle à la sérénité je
demande que cessent les polémiques
stériles qui n'apporte rien sinon que
d'inquiéter inutilement nos concitoyens
déjà fatigué et à fleur de peau du fait
de la durée et de l'ampleur de cette
crise inédite
on ne peut pas alors que le match vient
de commencer et qu'il durera plusieurs
mois prétendent dès les premières
minutes que dis-je dès les premières
secondes qu'il ait déjà perdu
bien au contraire nous relèverons
ensemble le pari de la vaccination et
nous surmonterons ce défi historique
nous voulons à la fois permettre
l'exercice d'un véritable droit à la
vaccination
cette organisées en fonction de
priorités sanitaires et convaincre le
maximum d'entre vous précisément parce
que nous avons pris toutes les garanties
éthique et médical de se faire vacciner
se faire vacciner et c'est se protéger
soi même mais c'est aussi protéger les
autres
montrons que nous sommes une nation
solidaire une nation général
j'en appelle une nouvelle fois pas notre
sens des responsabilités individuelles
et collectives
mes chers concitoyens une phase nouvelle
de la lutte contre la pandémie s'est
ouverte il s'agit d'un défi humain et
logistique considérable et inédit qui
nécessite patience et détermination et
je ne doute pas de notre succès
collectif
je maintiens mesdames et messieurs à
votre disposition
c'est le premier ministre vont jour
camille collin pour tf1 et lci
vous avez dit tout à l'heure prendre la
menace du variant britannique du virus
est très au sérieux
l'om est ce ce matin a demandé à
l'europe d'en faire plus face à une
situation qu'elle qualifie d' alarmante
alors la france doit-elle justement en
faire plus
et comment est ce que la piste d'une
fermeture des écoles est envisagée ou de
vacances scolaires qui durerait plus
longtemps pour enrayer la contagion de
cette souche est ce qu'un nouveau
confinement est lui aussi envisagé est
ce qu'il ne faut pas comme le disait
l'un des membres du conseil scientifique
frappé tôt efforts pour éviter de se
retrouver dans la situation anglaise car
si on va on va pas charger les embêter
dont je vais faire deux questions par
deux questions d'accord parce que le
ministre peut se préparer
bonsoir monsieur le prémice ton jaune à
van aelst pour bfm tv
au vu des chiffres qui en ce début
d'année ne sont pas très satisfaisant
avec les cas on le voit qui augmente à
nouveau sommes nous pas en train de
payer les fêtes de fin d'année et
notamment noël avec les nombreuses
familles françaises qui ont pu se réunir
à noël et puis deuxième qui deuxième
question que répondez-vous aux
différents présidents de région qui vous
qui demandent en fait de et bien deux
d'acheter même pardon d'acheter
eux-mêmes les doses de vaccin pour aller
plus vite merci
alors je le ministre voudra bien
compléter mon propos notamment par
rapport à l oms
voyez ça c'est le sait le sel de ma
fonction et mesdames vous me dites est
ce qu'on ne paye pas les fêtes de fin
d'année notamment noël
après m'avoir accusée de sacrifier noël
vous en souvenez quand on a pris les
décisions donc un courant c'est trop et
puis les mêmes 15 jours après vous
reproche de ne pas en faire assez
sans doute que la vérité est au juste
milieu pour ceux qui en tout cas des
fêtes de fin d'année c'était la deuxième
la deuxième question comme je les dis
dans mon intervention il vous le savez
d'ailleurs pour connaître l'impact
épidémique je porte me met sous le
contrôle mises à santé je pense qu'il
est encore un peu tôt pour pouvoir
l'apprécier de façon claire il n'y a pas
que noël je dirais sur l'ensemble de la
période
donc je vous ai indiqué que le temps qui
est devant nous pour ce motif madame
votre question est très pertinente est
crucial c'est à dire voyez si on laisse
s'écouler c'est à peu près au milieu de
la semaine prochaine que nous aurons des
données consolidées les fermetures des
écoles juste olivier veyrat vous vous
répondra sur le plan c comment sanitaire
vous me permettrez une remarque plus
générale nous avons eu à faire face si
j'ose dire
et comme le dit jean michel blanquer à
plusieurs rentrées scolaires depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire
avec un premier confinement ou les
écoles avaient été vous vous en souvenez
toutes et tous fermés on en a tiré des
enseignements en disant vraiment que je
crois d'ailleurs c'est que c'est ce que
dit ou écrit aussi le ms ou un entre
institutions que la la fermeture des
écoles devaient être envisagée vraiment
dernier recours je sais que certains
pays ont recouru ma position est que
effectivement il faut vraiment que
l'association sanitaire soit gravissime
pour fermer des écoles car nous savons
que les conséquences y compris sanitaire
de la fermeture des écoles sont
absolument dramatiques
j'observe d'ailleurs nous suivons tous
les jours tous les jours la situation
des clusters décontamination dans les
écoles dans les collèges dans les lycées
qui je vous rappelle ont déjà vu leur
fonctionnement allégées avant les
vacances de noël nous suivons tous les
jours cette situation et la dernière
rentrée s'est réalisée de façon tout à
fait je le dis satisfaisante par rapport
à ce qui se passe en grande-bretagne
décision a été prise dès que nous avons
eu les premières données de renforcer
dessus la surveillance épidémiologique
et des tests dans les écoles et le
ministre aura l'occasion de vous
présenter la montée en charge de cette
politique de dépistage dans les écoles
en particulier dans les lycées qui est
déjà comme je le disais très élevé je
termine en vous répondant sur les
présidents de région je veux dire toutes
les bonnes volontés sont bienvenues
aucun sujet
simplement la fourniture de doses
vaccinales vous le savez fait l'objet de
très fortes tensions au niveau mondial
notez bien je parle sous le contrôle
experts de manière une hache et que les
doses qui sont livrés maintenant ont été
commandés ou pré réservés il ya de très
nombreux mois et que là nous discutons
de doses supplémentaires parce que nous
cherchons aussi à accroître les
commandes et les réponses qui nous sont
faites sans plus tôt pour le quatrième
trimestre de l'année 2021 donc je je ne
suis pas certain que les régions où
d'autres organismes
s'agissant de grosses commandes d'états
qui sont vous le savez coordonner au
sein de l'union européenne par un
certain nombre de pays
je ne suis pas certain donc cette
excellente intentions louables des
régions ne puisse se concrétiser à court
terme
monsieur misa santé vous avez fait une
réponse exhaustive monsieur le premier
ministre
ça va être juste lire sur cette question
de cette question des régions par
ailleurs que les régions sont associés
de façon très étroite à la concertation
sur la stratégie vaccinale depuis depuis
des semaines et des semaines il ya eu
des communiqués certains saluaient la
qualité de la constatation et pour ne
rien vous cacher je ne vous dirai pas
qui j'ai ennuyé un 24 décembre à 20h30
en appelant pour lui parler de la
stratégie vaccinale mais ça ne s'est pas
arrêtée pendant pendant les vacances et
je ne doute pas une seconde que les plus
inquiets des présidents de région qui
depuis quelques jours font valoir leur
inquiétude salueront la montée en
puissance de la vaccination dans notre
pays
puisqu'il en va de l'intérêt de la
nation que d'être soudés dans cette
période
et puisque ce que nous voulons c'est
donner confiance aux français et leur
dire que nous sommes là pour les
protéger
vous avez parlé du variant anglais j'ai
dit tout à l'heure le ce qui a été mis
en oeuvre c'est à dire qu'on fait je
veux pas être rentré trop dans le détail
mais sachez que il ya plusieurs méthodes
de tests pcr c'est les thèses les
techniques de laboratoire ce qui permet
de faire les diagnostics
parmi ces méthodes il y en a une qui
permet de suspecter la mutation anglaise
ça tombe bien c'est un tiers du parc de
pc air de notre pays et donc quand on a
une mutation qui douteuses quand on a
une épaisseur qui est douteuse on
l'envoie dans un labo l'a fait un
travail beaucoup plus compliqué est ce
qu'on appelle un séquençage du génome du
virus qui permet d'avoir la cartographie
génétique précise du virus et de dire ça
selvaria anglais ou que ça ça l'est pas
est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
demain ce que les scientifiques font
aujourd'hui et demain c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'ils un test qui est positif
s'il est douteux et bien ils font le
séquençage s'il a été fait en sur une
pcr qui ne permet pas de dépister le
variant il est refait sur une technique
qui permet de le dépister hélas il est
douteux et bien c'est du séquençage donc
on sera combien de cas aujourd'hui de
variants anglais étaient apparus sur
notre territoire national combien demain
ce qui nous permet d'avoir une idée de
l'état de la circulation du virus je le
dis tout à l'heure 19 quatre variants à
ce stade ça vous paraît peut-être
beaucoup c'est peu par rapport aux 20
mille cas quotidiens que nous
enregistrons dans le pays
ce serait une bonne nouvelle est
évidemment si c'était limite et je pense
qu'il en a plus il faut qu'on vérifie si
c'est un petit peu plus quelques
dizaines ou si c'est déjà plus le plus
important nous devons vraiment tout
faire pour limiter ce variant ne m'ont
pas parce qu'il est anglais mais parce
que il est plus contagieux il est plus
contagieux et donc il prend le ça arrive
dans toute l'histoire des virus que vous
avez un virus qui mute et une espèce de
sélection naturelle chez virus qui fait
que plus un virus et méchant est bien
plus va circuler à la place des autres
et nous ne voulons pas subir ce que les
anglais ont subi qui s'en sont pas rendu
compte qu'il pouvait pas le savoir au
début nous ne voulons pas que ce variant
ce virus là qui est plus contagieux
prennent la place du virus que nous
connaissons en soit nous voulons plus du
tout que les virus circulent mais tant
qu'à faire autant éviter que ce soit le
variant anglais parce qu'il est plus
contagieux y'a pas de 15 encore une fois
y avait des suspicions des articles
qu'ils aient peut-être qu'il est plus
grave
il n'y a aucune démonstration
scientifique c'est même plutôt l'inversé
sur le fait qu'il serait plus dangereux
une fois que vous l'avez mais il est
plus contagieux et donc il faut lutter
contre merci ministres juste en
complément on m'a dit vous voulez vous
ne devriez vous pas reconfirmer je les
dis dans mon propos tout à l'heure la
france art confiné plus tôt que les
autres et ce n'est pas de s'en expliquer
malgré tout un taux d'incidence
inquiétant mais plus bas qu'ailleurs un
taux de positivité des tests plus
favorable nous avions pris cette
décision aujourd'hui vous m'inciter à
prendre la même je rappelle recombiner
par exemple ça veut dire fermer les
commerces qui ne vendent pas des
produits de première nécessité je n'ai
pas souvenir d'avoir à l'époque reçu de
chaleureuses félicitations pour avoir
pris cette décision douloureuse
qu'aujourd'hui vous semble régner
m'inciter à décider ce qui me conduit à
vous dire que nous avons par ailleurs je
n'ai peut-être pas assez cité dans mon
propos solliciter les organismes
scientifiques pour évaluer un autre
outil qu'est le couvre feu que nous
avons que je les appelais étant dit dans
son amplitude horaire un certain nombre
de départements 15 à ce jour et 25 à
partir de dimanche pour voir dans quelle
mesure cette ce levier si vous me passez
cette expression est efficace par
rapport au confinement pour lutter
contre la pandémie et faire reculer le
taux d'incidence je vous écoute
monsieur premier nice bonjour thierry
kurt et france 2 c'est un maire certains
élus qui souhaitent prendre des
initiatives comme par exemple ouvrir des
centres de vaccination se plaignent
d'avoir à faire un véritable mille
feuille administratif et d'avoir jusqu'à
plus d'une quinzaine d' interlocuteur
dans les différentes administrations
publiques est-ce que c'est pas là l'une
des raisons qui explique que l on soit
dans un certain nombre de blocages
est-ce que vous allez simplifier ces
démarches et puis deuxième question un
certain nombre d'informations peut être
des rumeurs qui n'ont pas forcément été
vérifié je vous demande je vous pose la
question font état d'un certain nombre
de pays européens qui cherchent et qui
essayent d'acheter en parallèle un
certain nombre de doses vaccinales
est ce que c'est le cas est-ce que vous
avez des informations à ce sujet alors
on va on va d'abord je vais on va faire
une par une donc ça va me donner
l'occasion de faire venir je vous
remercie de votre élégance monsieur de
faire venir ma bannière une hache et au
pupitre puisque vous avez posé une
question sur les approvisionnements en
europe vous avez moi je répond
directement à la question sur des mers
parce que vous comprendrez que c'est un
sujet que que j'affectionne
particulièrement on est bien d'accord la
priorité du jour du début comme on l'a
toujours dit ces départs dehors des
mères peuvent être j'en fus président
d'établissement hébergeant des ehpad
bien mais là c'est un circuit très dédié
un centre de vaccination en tout cas je
suppose que c'est votre question ce
quelque chose où les gens sera on ne va
pas faire sortir les résidents des ehpad
pour aller dans les centres de
vaccination il faut aller vers le temps
qu'on est déjà dans une étape ultérieure
que j'ai longuement évoquée puisque j'ai
parlé de ces centres de vaccination et
je vous confirme pour à nouveau les
saluer que beaucoup de maires se porte
candidat pour épauler l'état et c'est
très heureux dans
le déploiement de la vaccination donc on
leur répond entraîné et je pense avoir
été très clair monsieur je le répète
peut-être un écho à vos interrogations
en tout cas à celle que vous relayer le
patron du déploiement de la stratégie
vaccinale pendant l'état avec les
agences régionales de santé
c'est le préfet de département ya un
pilote dans l'avion et je savais j'ai
souvent parlé du couple maire préfet
s'est pas première fois les maires ils
connaissent le préfet de département
sont des gens pragmatiques qu'ils savent
faire
en fait le pari de confiance ils vont
travailler ensemble et vous verrez
progressivement
évidemment ce jeu je vous fais toute
confiance battu ici ou là il y aura
sûrement un loupé rater ça je ne doute
pas que nous pourrons le corriger car il
ne sera pas passer sous silence
ça c'est la certitude que j'ai la même
distance merci beaucoup monsieur le
premier ministre peut être remettre en
perspective comment se sont déroulées
ces achats de doses vaccinales au niveau
européen les quantités dont on parle
que ce soit pour moderna pour kaiser
pour sanofi puisqu'on a parlé aussi de
ce vaccin pour jansen et pour
astrazeneca ont été sécurisés entre juin
et septembre
les quantités c'est à dire que dans
chaque cas il ya eu des pré accord qui
ensuite ont donné lieu à des contrats
plus longs dont lesquels un certain
nombre de clauses était discutée mais
les quantités elles ont été verrouillés
il y a entre 6 et ou même sept et cinq
mois et c'est ces quantités aujourd'hui
qui sont livrés avec des capacités
industrielles
et sous forte tension on peut même
considérer qu'elles sont saturés et
notre travail consiste à faire en sorte
d'accompagner la montée en puissance de
ses capacités industrielles
mais un transfert technologique d'une
je dirais d'un laboratoire
pharmaceutique vers un sous traitant
ça prend 12 mois à 18 mois en temps
normal
donc nous sommes face à une prouesse
industrielle ou de manière générale
chacun pousse les plus gros sites de son
pays pour pouvoir fabriquer le maximum
de dos donc ce qui est négocié
aujourd'hui d'hervé nouveaux apports
comme l'a dit monsieur le premier
ministre
ce sont des quantités qui arrive au
deuxième semestre voire en fin de
deuxième semestre pour des raisons
évidentes de montée en puissance des
capacités industrielles et au niveau
européen
je ne lis pas dans le marc de café je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe dans l'arrière
boutique de chacun des états mais tel
qui est con ce qu'un tel que sont conçus
les contrats il n'est pas matériellement
possible de livrer à la fois les
contractuels et de donner des deux en
plus c'est pas de la boulangerie et des
baguettes que nous fabriquons c'est des
vaccins et donc ça demande un minimum de
mots location de site de transfert
technologique de conditions rigoureuses
de monter en puissance et encore une
fois je crois qu'il faut saluer
l'exploit industriel qui a été réalisé
après l'exploit de recherche et
développement par les différents
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et comme
vous l'avez vu ils courent tous aussi
vite que possible et nous notre travail
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on fabrique
et je voulais signaler qu'il ya trois
sites en france qui vont fabriquer des
vaccins donnés dans les prochaines
semaines donc ils sont entre n 2 de
montée en puissance réussie farm pour le
vaccin moderna delpharm pour le vaccin
bayod ntech et si le vaccin curve ac est
effectivement validé fareva produira ce
vaccin au delà effectivement des sites
de sanofi il faut peut-être ajouter
monsieur que
notre position est très claire le plan
de république a rappelé dans le cadre de
cette organisation et de cette
discipline européenne
nous entendons respecter parce que a
perdu permis d'avoir des précommandes en
quantité très élevée et à des à des prix
satisfaisants si des doses vaccinales se
trouve être disponible l'instruction est
clair la france achètera tout de suite
d'accord j'ai peut-être une précision
effectivement c'est à dire que il y à un
moment où chaque payer réinterroger sur
voulez vous prendre votre quota
populationnelle ou pas et donc vous avez
des pays qui ont décidé de pas
nécessairement prendre la totalité de
leurs quotas populationnelle pour des
raisons qui leur appartient notamment
des soucis logistiques notamment des
soucis de distribution peu importe des
soucis budgétaires peu importe
et dans ce cas la lidho sont remis en
jeu et chacun des pays ont la capacité à
redemander des douces donc c'est comme
ça que ça se passe et ça peut expliquer
que vous n'ayez pas toujours une
réplication linéaire du populationnelle
mais parce qu'il ya un premier tour et
un deuxième tour et que certains pays on
renonçait à prendre des douches
monsieur morel monsieur le premier
ministre je voulais justement vous
interroger sur ce sujet est ce à dire
donc qu'il n'y aura pas nécessité de
transférer en tout cas d' inciter les
industriels à dole et des licences à
d'autres industriels et on vous écoute
on est ce que ces vaccins sont fabriqués
et seront donc vous dites fabriqué en
france pas nécessairement envoyer du
pays producteurs faille il faudrait
peut-être préciser monsieur le premier
ministre je voulais vous poser une
question vraiment beaucoup plus général
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
que la polémique est que nous avons
connue sur la vaccination a peut être
incité ou vous a peut-être fait nous a
peut-être fait prendre conscience que
les français avaient finalement envie de
se faire vacciner que c'était peut-être
un grand changement psychologique que
nous découvrons
chez nos compatriotes mais en fait la
question principale des tables rondes et
des polémiques en suicidé en vis est
effectué un très heureux madame la
ministre
oui alors dans la négociation que nous
avons menées avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
nous avons veillé à ce qu'il y ait des
chaînes de production en europe ses
chaînes de production elles sont pour le
dire très simplement constitué de deux
étapes une première étape pour vous
fabriquer le principe actif drac
substence et une deuxième étape où vous
remplissez les petites bouteilles pour
faire très court
ces deux étapes nécessite une d
homologation des de chacun des
laboratoires qui les produisent
et vous avez des contrats de sous
traitance vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir
un problème de propriété intellectuelle
je rappelle d'ailleurs que sur
astrazeneca c'est le sait oxford qui a
la propriété intellectuelle sur baillons
intex et bayod attaqué pape faisait donc
à chaque fois ils voyaient d'ailleurs
vous avez celui qui a conçu le vaccin
qui va ensuite chercher un spécialiste
de l'industrialisation pour très vite
montée en puissance lequel spécialiste
de l'industrialisation va chercher des
sous traitants qui ont des sites
homologué
c'est pas la même chose d'avoir un site
homologué pour un virus inactivé puisque
c'est des laboratoires p2 que d'avoir un
arn vous avez des spécificités et
ensuite vous allez au plus gros sites
parce que le transfert technologique
prend autant de temps sur un petit site
ou sur un gros site
donc là le fait d'être très efficace
oblige aléas des gros sites et donc la
france sur certains vaccins est
positionné sur la fabrication du
principe actif sur d'autres sur leur en
prit dans le remplissage des bouteilles
et je précisais une chose j mentionner
les six femmes delpharm fareva ce sont
des sous traitants ces trois sous
traitants vont fabriquer pour l'europe
et l'intelligence de la logistique va
probablement faire que ce sera plutôt
des doses qui rompt en france en
belgique fin au plus près
de là où elles sont produites mais ça
c'est le laboratoire pharmaceutique qui
a contractualisé qui organisera la
distribution en revanche c'est pas par
hasard qu'ils à cette production
c'est parce que nous avons lancé un
appel à projet au mois de juin avec
olivier ferrand pour précisément
permettre de renforcer nos capacités de
production de médicaments utilisés dans
le cadre du mali tron la lutte contre la
copie ou pour des potentiels candidats
vaccins que aujourd'hui vous avez deux
de ses laboratoires
deux de ses sous-traitants delpharm et
fareva qui bénéficient d'un soutien
public pour accélérer la production et
le troisième a déposé également un
dossier qui est en cours d'instruction
j'espère que c'est plus clair comme ça
très bien je réponds à un peu plus
complètement à la question touristique
de monsieur monsieur moore elle vous
pour vous dire à toutes et à tous on est
en début d'année cette crise a dit moi
on va bien qu'on gère malheureusement
quelque chose qui s'est installé dans la
durée qu'on n'aurait pas prévu où
certains n'ont pas voulu
donc il faut gérer ce temps long vous
avez observé que j'ai volontairement
fait un point précis sur la stratégie
testé à l'époque alerte est protégée
parce que je pense qu'elle va continuer
à être appliquée encore pendant quelques
mois parce qu'elle sera très utile et je
défère donnant le maximum de données que
vous pouvez vérifier sur le déploiement
de cette stratégie
qu'est-ce qu'elles démontrent non pas
qu'il n'y a pas eu de difficultés
auxquelles peu de problèmes il y en a eu
comme dans tous les pays mais qu' elle
est sans doute l'une des plus
performants d'europe
nous testons le plus avec des délais un
moyen des plus courts on sait encore où
sont nos marges de progrès on va mettre
le moins les moyens dessus notamment sur
l'effectivité de l' isolement
mais c'est une stratégie qui s'est
déployée de manière satisfaisante
et pourtant et pourtant avant le
soi-disant échec les vaccins on lit
partout comme si c'était une doll est
d'évidence
les tests ça marche pas mais c'est faux
mais c'est faux j'ai encore une fois qui
a des problèmes bien des difficultés
mais quand on se compare avec les autres
et elles sont gratuits et essor rapide
et qu'elles sont sûres en france
l'assurance maladie déploient des moyens
considérables pour assurer le traçage
l'application tout senti qu vide
après quelques difficultés démarrage a
progressé de manière significative
voilà donc tout ça s'inscrit dans la
durée vous avez raison c'est noël il
faut penser que c'est aussi la durée le
sérieux que nous administrons dans le
déploiement des vaccins qui renforceront
l'adhésion de nos concitoyens le vrai
test en fait bien sûr c'est celui qu'on
y en a combien là on veut connais
beaucoup le vrai test c'est parmi les
populations dans votre ehpad madame
qu'on va vacciner chez les plus de 75
ans demain chez les soignants
aujourd'hui quel est le pourcentage de
ceux qui se feront effectivement
vaccinés c'est ça le défi collectif
c'est ça le défi qui pend et donc voilà
nous devons j'ai employé l'expression ne
pas confondre vitesse et précipitation
répondre à ceux qui veulent quand les
vaccine c'est notre devoir c'est pas
d'entrevoir c'est notre objectif mais
aussi parce qu'on fait pas les choses
importera parce qu'on ne croise pas le
consentement des gens parce qu'on
respecte les considérations éthiques
suscitées le plus d'adhésions possible
c'est ça aussi une stratégie vaccinale
ce n'est pas mais vous le savez
parfaitement qu'une question logistique
c'est une question logistique majeur
bien entendu mais c'est aussi une
question psychologique parce que là
succès de cette stratégie vaccinale
repose à des gens surtout de ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin pour eux mêmes et
pour protéger les autres le système
hospitalier et je ne vous apprendrai pas
osé
autre que nous sommes un pays bien avant
l'arrivée de l'aco vide où l'engouement
dont les vaccins n'est pas parmi les
plus développés
effectivement vous avez raison
finalement là je vois que il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui
interviennent en parlant des vaccins
avec une forme d'appétit qui me réjouit
on va leur donner satisfaction
allez on va prendre encore une ou deux
questions bon sens le spray ministre
peureux bria à gazon france presse afp
d'abord une précision vous avez dit ce
soir qui vient frontière avec le royaume
uni allait rester fermé qu'est ce que ça
veut dire précisément ça veut dire que
c'est le statu quo au contraire que des
mesures plus restrictives à d'être mise
en place est une deuxième question mi
décembre devant le parlement
vous aviez indiqué qu'un million 800
mille doses seraient disponibles en
france ou vers le 6 janvier
nous y sommes manifestement ces doses ne
sont pas d'accord est ce que c'est un
problème de production industrielle ou
est ce que c'est un problème de
logistique de stockage en france qui
explique que cette promesse n'a pas été
tenue
merci donc à nouveau merci de faire
venir à notre ministre au pupitre pour
cette histoire de doses j'ai déjà vu
cette question on va vous répondre
pour la grande bretagne soyons clairs
donc pour l'instant je n'aurais pas
façon être précis c'est le statu quo je
parle sous le contrôle des gens
spécialisés on a dû reprendre un décret
parce que les mesures de fermeture qu'on
avait pris s'achevait le si ce monsieur
c'est ça donc on les a prolongées oui
c'est le statu quo donc les frontières
sont fermées et pour les les citoyens
français qui réside en grande bretagne
est pur il ya surtout à fait surtout le
pape des routiers que je vois un test au
départ porte le présenta et publiques
nous devons lui faire rapport a demandé
à ce que soit bien évalué les
modalités d'application de ces
dispositions de mesurer aussi c'était le
sans intervention du ministre de la
santé les l'impact des informations
scientifiques que nous disposons au fur
et à mesure chaque jour davantage sur ce
virus mutant là aussi je pense je parle
son contrôle qu'un avis du conseil
scientifique sur ce sujet précis est
attendu pour le début de la semaine
prochaine
mardi je crois et donc nous pourrions
être amenés à prendre des mesures
soyons clairs certainement pas dans les
gisements du dispositif certainement pas
alors sur les fameux 1,8 million de
doses madame la ministre je crois que
c'était la fin du mois de janvier donc
ça recoupe les chiffres qu'on vient de
vous donner ce qui avait été dit au mois
de décembre et nous sommes comme l'a
très bien indiqué monsieur le ministre
de la santé has enfants soixante mille
doses livrées chaque semaine donc on
sera tout à fait dans c'est
niveau donc c'est nier un problème
l'industrialisation ni un problème de
pardon de logistique c'est tout
simplement une question de compréhension
de tableaux probablement voilà alors une
dernière question madame propos du délai
d'injection entre les deux doses la
deuxième dose
le laboratoire pfizer avait dit qu'il
préférait pas qu'on reporte au delà de
trois semaines
vous dites que vous allez reporté
jusqu'à six semaines est-ce que c'est
pas plus dangereux pour l'efficacité du
vaccin qui vous donne l'autorisation
vous parlez des autorités sanitaires
parce que c'est là nsm la haute autorité
de santé
et justement est-ce que c'est pas plus
dangereux de reporter en tout cas c'est
moins efficace pour le vaccin de
reporter la deuxième dose est comment
allez-vous faire justement pour gérer
les douze là-dessus ce point là en tout
cas le seul but de santé il y aura bien
une deuxième injection
parce que vous auriez plus aussi posé
cette question par rapport à des
pratiques de pays amis je ne peux pas
croire que vous puissiez croire qu'on
prendrait une décision qui serait
dangereux sont qui conduirait être moins
efficace vu tout ce qu'on fait pour
organiser la stratégie vaccinale dans le
pays c'est qu'on a envie que ça serve
c'est pour le plaisir de l'injection
c'est pour que ça puisse être efficace
et protéger les français
non ce qui est de relève des
informations des scientifiques ont eu
c'est que ça ne peut pas la deuxième
injection de rappel ne peut pas avoir
lieu moins de 21 jours moins de trois
semaines avant la moins de trois
semaines après la première injection
sinon là on a une perte d'efficacité
c'était ce qui relevait de l'étude et
ensuite ils ont observé c'est qu'il ya
des patients et dans le cadre du
protocole et dans le cas des de la
vaccination qui ont une injection plus
tardive que les trois semaines et même
certains ont une injection beaucoup plus
tardif que les trois semaines et que
c'est très bien passé donc les données
dont nous disposons et évidemment ne
fait pas ça sent la vie
conforme des autorités sanitaires en
l'occurrence la rsm je ne sais plus si
la chasse la haute autorité de santé a
eu à se prononcer mais tout est
parfaitement conforme et si je vous
l'annoncé qu' on est back et de ce point
de vue là tu peux parler par les
scientifiques et les acteurs de la santé
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question donc
dès que je fais je me ferai vacciner
je souhaite ardemment me faire vacciner
je le saurai quand mon tour viendra
voilà merci bon figaro live merci d'être
avec nous nous sommes en direct
après cette nouvelle déclaration du
gouvernement avec d'un côté jean castex
qui a pris la parole pendant est bien de
longues minutes ça fait désormais 1h20
que cette prise de parole a commencé
nous avons également entendu pas mal de
déclarations de olivier ferrand le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
on a pu également apercevoir agnès
pannier-runacher et enfin et bien une
directrice d pad qui a expliqué un petit
peu la situation qui avait lieu au sein
de son établissement
notamment en ce qui concerne les vaccins
merci à tous d'être avec nous sur
youtube vous vous êtes nombreux je vous
en remercie je vais vous salue et
d'ailleurs pour pas là pour vous
remercier d'être avec nous merci
gameloft onion yanis remy surimi merci
marie lys rayhana voilà je ne pourrais
pas tous vous citez vous êtes
extrêmement nombreux mais je vous en
remercie n'hésitez pas bien continuer de
d'interagir de poser vos questions
également
on prend tous vos commentaires comme il
en est de coutume un petit point que
nous allons faire tout de suite pour
justement revoir un petit peu ce qui a
été dit pendant et bien cette 1h20 de
déclaration qui est bien et donc nous a
apporté pas mal d'informations
supplémentaires à commencer par et bien
la réouverture des différents
établissements fermés depuis désormais
plusieurs semaines et donc cette
réouverture qui n'aura pas lieu on le
sait tout d'abord et bien avant la fin
du mois en ce qui concerne les musées
les cinémas les équipements sportifs les
stations de ski également qu'ils ne
peuvent donc pas rouvrir c'était cette
date du 7 janvier qui était attendue
depuis longtemps par les acteurs
économiques et culturels qu'on n'avait
pu notamment voir manifester à la fin du
mois de décembre dans les rues de la
capitale pourrait bien justement appelé
à la réouverture de leurs établissements
et donc eh bien il va falloir en tout
cas attendre la fin du mois et même est
bien en ce qui concerne les restaurants
et bars au moins la mi février
voilà donc pour l'impact économique qui
touche bien ces différents
établissements
il va donc falloir encore être patient
et surtout et bien continuer d'observer
l'évolution de l'épidémie pour savoir eh
bien si l' ouverture sera possible en
tout cas à ces dates là ou pas ce que
l'on sait également et bien c'est qu'un
nouveau point de situation sera fait par
le gouvernement le 20 janvier donc le
rendez vous en direct sur fear alive
poursuivre ses déclarations et ses
décisions voilà donc le 20 janvier avec
pas mal d'informations qui devrait
provenir en ce qui concerne les parvenir
par dans ce qui concerne les vaccins les
différents traitements qui ont lieu
l'évolution de la situation mais
également comme vient de l'annoncer les
différents les différentes questions de
situation économique ce que l'on sait
également
c'est bien de nouvelles informations en
ce qui concerne le variant du virus le
variant britannique qui donc est apparue
il ya quelques semaines et qui bien un
bel et bien dépassé la frontière franco
britannique avec et bien désormais on
sait de la part d'olivier veyrat 19 cas
du var et en anglais qui ont été
identifiés en france
ce que l'on sait également c'est que et
bien la fermeture des frontières avec le
royaume uni va-t-elle être et bien
continuer jusqu'à nouvel ordre il faudra
encore là aussi être vigilants et à deux
patients si on veut avoir des nouvelles
là dessus en ce qui concerne la
réouverture des frontières avec nos
voisins britanniques qui viennent de
quitter l'union européenne ces derniers
jours pourrait bien commencer l'année
2021 avec une nouvelle deux breaks site
ce que l'on sait également est bien
c'est que les mesures de couvre-feu
vont-elles également être et bien
continuer pendant plusieurs semaines
avec aussi dans un autre cas est bien
dix départements de l'est qui pourrait
bien faire l'objet d'un couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures c'est déjà le cas
pour certains départements français est
bien dit nouveaux départements
pourraient bien devoir se se confiner à
partir de 18h faudra là aussi sur ceux
là pendant les semaines à venir
en ce qui concerne les vaccins et bien
on s'est un peu plus d'information on le
sait la france est particulièrement en
retard en ce qui concerne les vaccins
contrairement à notamment à ses voisins
internationaux chinois ou américains eh
bien on sait une précommande 200
millions de doses de vaccin a été fait
il faudra donc bien suivre les
évolutions de cette situation vaccinale
en france
ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que bien
jean castex le premier ministre veut que
l'on puissent vacciner un million de
personnes
avant la fin du mois de janvier et enfin
olivier ferrand ministre de la santé et
des solidarités a affirmé lui que 70
millions de vaccins
avais tu étais pas donc 70 millions de
vaccins et bien serait en tout cas livré
avant l'été au sein de nos frontières
voilà pour en tout cas un gros un gros
récapitulatif de ce que l'on a pu
apprendre par le gouvernement et par et
bien olivier ferrand qui a pu nous
donner un peu plus de nouvelles passage
rapide par le chat merci à lyon 69 vous
nous demandez s'il y aura un couvre-feu
à 18 heures à lyon est bien pour moment
en tout cas ce n'est pas prévu c'est
plutôt en ce qui concerne l'est que nous
observerons potentiellement un passage à
18 heures voilà pour vous répondre on
sait également un peu plus
d'informations pour ismaël charkaoui sur
le youtube qui nous demande en ce qui
concerne les écoles vous faudra seront
elles fermées ça c'est ce qui vous fait
aussi particulièrement réagir c'est
votre cas par exemple en dong est jean
cas il vous ismaël qui posait cette
question et bien non les écoles les
différents établissements scolaires sont
bel et bien maintenu ouvert ce que nous
a expliqué le premier ministre jean
castex et que la situation devait
vraiment être au plus grave possible
pour envisager une fermeture des
établissements scolaires comme on a pu
l'observer à l'occasion du premier
confinement du 17 mars au 11 mai ces
derniers mois voilà en tout cas qui vous
répond également à vous ça sous merci en
tout cas d'être d'être avec nous ce soir
je vais essayer de prendre vos questions
vous êtes nombreux à interagir dans le
chat ça fait plaisir on vous salue tous
armés qu'à m
elin pérou nadia également merci à vous
jean lemaître haubané au ban par don
bigg front et olive également merci à
tous d'être avec nous merci lauriane
également lauriane l'upstairs j'espère
ne pas écorcher votre nom de famille
voilà vous êtes nombreux avec nous en
tout cas on est encore ensemble pour
plusieurs minutes
n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos questions
on va essayer de les prendre
on a super nocturne qui nous demandent
si les vacances seront prolongées du
coup alors ce qui concerne les vacances
d'hiver
eh bien il va falloir attendre le 20
janvier est le nouveau point du
gouvernement puisque jean castex a
indiqué que de nouvelles informations
concernant notamment et bien par exemple
la réouverture des stations de ski enfin
pas des stations de ski est plutôt des
remontées mécaniques au sein des
stations de ski vont avoir lieu donc en
tout cas en ce qui concerne les vacances
scolaires mais là il va falloir attendre
les prochaines semaines et cette date
importante du 20 janvier pour avoir une
évolution de la situation qui est bien
on l'a appris et bien n'est pas en tout
cas en bonne situation de handicap pour
se corriger et pour aller mieux et qui
donc présente toujours des statistiques
assez inquiétante
c'est ce que nous avons appris ce soir
avec le premier ministre on a aussi
beaucoup de questions en ce qui concerne
les facultés et nenê l'enseignement
supérieur notamment de vous titiller
yasmina et geneviève caru vous demander
quand est il des facultés des facs et
bien en ce qui concerne les facultés et
les facs et bien pas de fermetures
prévues
ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que bien
certains étudiants ont manifesté
aujourd'hui pour bien s'opposer à la
tenue des partielles dans des conditions
qu'il juge
et bien non conformes aux règles
sanitaires et donc bien pour le moment
voilà ce que l'on sait en ce qui
concerne cela en ce qui concerne
également le bac blanc et le brevet
blanc pour vous qu as kosovo vous ne
posez des questions là-dessus
et bien pas de nouvelles là dessus il va
falloir aussi attendre les prochaines
semaines et les prochaines évolutions de
la crise sanitaire et la situation
sanitaire au sein de nos frontières pour
avoir un peu plus d'informations
là-dessus pour ses diplômes de fin
d'année
bonsoir plus divine
chez ça vous le demande et si les
adultes pourront de retourner dans les
salles de sport et bien pour moment ce
n'est pas le cas c'est ce que nous avons
appris ce soir avec bien jean castex qui
nous a expliqué que les musées cinémas
équipements sportifs et bien ne serait
pas réouvert avant la fin du mois voilà
pour ces informations merci en tout cas
à vous d'être d'être avec nous merci
pour vos messages également ban kukumi
un bain vous êtes nombreux à de saluer
on vous salue également on a dit ah vous
le demander ici les cinémas sont ouverts
et bien non les cinémas comme l'ensemble
du monde culturel qui avaient manifesté
dans les rues parisiennes notamment à
bastille et bien en fin du mois de
décembre
et bien ne seront toujours pas ouvert
avant la fin du mois de janvier
il va donc falloir attendre encore une
fois je le répète bien cette date du 20
janvier pour avoir un peu plus
d'informations sur c'est sûr c'est sur
ces ouvertures qui concerne de nombreux
acteurs qu'ils soient culturels mais
également économiques sains que ce soit
dans le tourisme dans le milieu de la
restauration des bars pour bien les
cinémas ce qu'on vient d'aborder pour
les musées avec notamment et bien bien
c'est serré ouverture kikuku qui
continuent d'être à la fois difficile
pour les esprits mais également pour la
situation économique d'un grand nombre
de français voilà en tout cas pour vous
répondre j'ai encore des questions en ce
qui concerne les lycées c'est vous à
nicolas david qui nous demandaient rien
ne change en tout cas pour le moment sur
cette situation
des écoles lycées collèges pas
d'informations sûres sur cela il va
falloir attendre le mois de janvier mais
en tout cas pour le moment pas de
fermetures en vue c'est ce que nous
avons appris ce soir
merci en tout cas de de vos messages
bonsoir flavio flaugnatti vous le
demande et si on peut voyager en
outre-mer bien oui à condition est bien
de présenter un un test je pense qu'ils
soient pas qu'ils ne soient pas positif
oco vide 19 nous allons accueillir si je
ne m'abuse
mathieu siro qui est journaliste au
service politique du figaro je vais être
mon petit masque pour l'accueillir
n'hésitez pas à nous poser toutes vos
questions si vous souhaitez bien des
récollets récapitulatif mais également
aimé un peu plus d'informations et
d'observations sur les verts l'évolution
politique de cette crise bonsoir matines
vous pouvez vous installer avec le thé
merci d'être avec nous je vais vous
faire apparaître je vous invite à vous
rapprocher très légèrement deux mois
pour qu'on puisse vous voir dans le
cadre et voilà la magie du direct
nous sommes ensemble vous avez bien
regardé très certainement sur figure
live
cette déclaration du premier ministre
d'olivier ferrand il y avait gagné
spaniard une hache-- également qu'est ce
que vous en retenez dans les grandes
lignes politiques de ces déclarations il
n'y a pas vraiment de grandes annonces
de grands changements dans la vie des
français
à partir de ce soir ou demain on voit
bien que là en ce moment le gouvernement
est dans une sorte d'entre deux pourquoi
parce qu'en fait il ya plusieurs données
encore qui sont pas consolidées le
gouvernement cherchait à savoir si ce
virus mutant il y en a plusieurs en
celui du royaume-uni celui d'afrique du
sud va se propager sur le territoire ou
non et cherchent aussi à savoir si les
rassemblements de noël et du nouvel an
vont provoquer un rebond de l'épidémie
et ça pour le moment c'est trop tôt pour
le savoir
alors on voit que les contraintes sont
évidemment prolongée parce que jean
castex a insisté la situation reste
préoccupante
jusqu'au 20 janvier a priori peut-être
que ce sera une nouvelle fois prolongée
mais surtout il a dit qu'il était prêt à
réagir vite en cas de rebond de
l'épidémie donc on voit bien que ce qui
la menace qui plane sur le pays c'est
celle là effectivement d'une troisième
vague et d'un re confinement merci à
vous d'être avec nous je vois tous vos
commentaires vous avez aussi des
questions notamment le veau de justin
qui ne demandait si vous peut passer
vous pouvez passer par nous pour poser
des questions aux ministres alors
malheureusement non puisque nos noms
retransmettant ces images en direct du
figaro mais nous ne sommes pas présents
aux conférences de presse qui ne sont
pas à l'interactive en ce qui concerne
cela mais on peut prendre vos questions
on peut vous répondre également alors je
le répète en ce qui concerne la
fermeture des différents établissements
économiques restaurants bars notamment
et bien là il va falloir attendre
normalement avant la mi la moitié du
mois de février donc il va falloir être
être en tout cas patients notamment pour
les acteurs économiques qui sont
particulièrement impactés depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois par les
conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire
merci à vous on a également une question
d'âme san qui ne demandait qu en est il
du télétravail y at il une prolongation
alors on sait qu'il ya eu des
adaptations en ce qui concerne le
télétravail avec notamment la
possibilité pour les employés de venir
travailler une fois par semaine si en
tout cas leur employeur en est d'accord
voilà sur les dernières informations que
nous avons eues ces derniers jours ça
s'était pas déclarée
ce soir on a pu déceler mathilde
notamment à dans les réponses offertes
par le premier ministre notamment aux
journalistes présents ce soir face au
gouvernement une sorte un petit peu de
d'agacement vis à vis de certains
commentaires notamment le premier
ministre qui expliquait un peu
l'histoire de ma vie si je resterai les
fêtes on dit que c'est trop et si il ya
des malades à cause des fêtes
celle inverse on est critique aussi le
gouvernement qui est quand même dans une
situation particulièrement complexe au
fur et à mesure des semaines dans cette
crise sanitaire qui s'alourdit à chacun
à chaque mois c'est fait c'est assez
étonnant de voir que ce premier ministre
désormais condamne critique
à chaque fois les polémiques lille avait
déjà fait cette semaine une critique des
polémiques qu'il dit stérile elles ont
quand même servi à revoir la stratégie
de vaccination du gouvernement il faut
le noter et c'est aussi intéressant de
voir le décalage par rapport à emmanuel
macron qui lui met en scène sa colère il
tape du poing sur la table
ils l'expriment le fait qu'il me kim
n'est pas content parce que ça ne va pas
assez vite
et d'un autre côté un chef de
gouvernement qui dit il y en a marre des
polémiques stériles il faut arrêter et
c'est vrai que c'est un peu sa marque de
fabrique c'est à dire que déjà au mois
d'octobre donc on était au tout début de
la deuxième vague il
il avait l'habitude de dire j'ai à gérer
un lot dans merlin en même temps maire
de man inédit voilà c'est le propre des
premiers ministres on le sait la charge
est lourde d'autant plus dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire de crise
économique
mais je ne suis pas sûr en effet que que
cette posture que que cette faculté a
toujours s'en prendre aux commentateurs
aux polémiques c'est le lot de tout
gouvernement se soit véritablement utile
et surtout sam 9 ça n'empêchera en rien
les critiques et elles sont souvent
légitimes et constructive intéressant
dans ce cas de voir un petit peu
l'évolution des la rhétorique employée
par les différents noms du gouvernement
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois de
confinement
merci à vous un jeu je vois pas mal de
questions notamment en ce qui concerne
les vaccins
en tout cas en ce qui concerne les
vaccins ce que l'on a pu apprendre de
nouveau ce soir dans les déclarations du
gouvernement c'est que et bien le
gouvernement avait fait une pré commande
de 200 millions de doses de vaccins que
le premier ministre que l'on puissent
vacciner un million de français d'ici à
la fin du mois et enfin que bien 78
millions de vaccins seraient lee
en france avant l'été voilà pour
l'évolution on va vous faire un recap
notamment bbox qui est de demander cela
rester avec nous on va terminer
d'aborder cette cette analyse politique
se débride politique avec mathieu siro
journaliste au service économie du
figaro si vous avez politiques publiques
par louis général est bon
merci qui donc voilà pour pouvoir vous
permettre de poser vos questions
n'hésitez pas nous sommes encore
ensemble quelques minutes
voilà donc pour cette cette annonce ce
soir là prochaine ce sera 20 janvier est
ce qu'on peut d'ores et déjà s'attendre
à certaines déclarations certaine mesure
où il est encore trop tôt pour le dire
c'est sûr que jean castex a donné rendez
vous au 20 janvier mais c'est un horizon
un peu nébuleux parce que même
concernant les salles de sport les bars
et les restaurants on sait que c'est
voilà la situation ne permet pas de les
rouvrir mais a donné rendez vous à la mi
février
en tout cas on peut s'attendre à ce que
effectivement le gouvernement s'exprime
de nouveau peut être la semaine
prochaine peut-être dans une dizaine de
jours quand il aura à sa portée des
nouvelles données des nouvelles données
sur la situation de l'épidémie si oui ou
non la france sera confrontée à une
troisième vague et si elle doit prendre
des mesures plus drastiques comme
certains voisins on pense au royaume uni
qui qui est confiné de manière assez
dieu parce que les écoles aussi sont
fermés et donc nous voilà il faut
s'attendre effectivement à ce qui est
peut-être de nouvelles mesures un
serrage de vis plus important en tout
cas en tout cas c'est bien ce qu'a dit
jean castex à il a dit qu'il n'excluait
pas du tout de prendre des mesures
supplémentaires et de réagir vite
il a beaucoup insisté comme pour
préparer un petit peu les esprits et il
faut quand même rappeler que d'ici à
demain il va y avoir une concertation
avec les élus locaux les élus de de 10
départements en plus de ceux qui sont
déjà soumis à un couvre-feu plus
strictes qui pourraient basculer
sous le régime d'un couvre-feu à 18
heures donc on voit que petit à petit la
carte de la france la carte des
restrictions progresse et peut-être que
voilà de nouveaux territoires vont
seront concernés la semaine prochaine le
gouvernement voilà et adapte sa
stratégie et choisit une réponse
territorialisées avant peut-être d'avoir
recours à des mesures nationales et un
confinement
merci beaucoup pour ce qu'analysent
merci journaliste au service politique
getafe figaro je remercie beaucoup pour
le débrief ce débrief de cette
déclaration on espère vous retrouver
très vite dans vos papiers pour le
figaro dès ce soir d'ailleurs je vous
remercie nous on va rester ensemble
encore quelques minutes pendant que
matinaux qui très bonne soirée à vous
pour bien justement faire un dernier
récapitulatif je vois notamment beaucoup
de vos questions dans le tchat
en ce qui concerne les biens notamment
la fermeture ou pas décollage et
différents établissements scolaires ou
d'enseignement supérieur c'est votre cas
noah marc badr ayachi soukèye
léo maurice alors pour vous répondre et
bien pas d'informations pas de nouvelles
sur la fermeture ou l'ouverture
enfin plutôt la fermeture sur les
prochaines semaines des différents
établissements scolaires qui reste bel
et bien ouvert un pas d'information là
dessus ou pas en tout cas d'évolution
nature la seule chose que nous a bien
expliqué le premier ministre sait que
pour envisager une fermeture des
établissements scolaires
il fallait une situation
particulièrement grave en ce qui
concerne les et des universités pardon
pour vous gigou une feuille une feuille
j'espère ne pas écorcher votre nom bien
les pour l'enseignement supérieur c'est
pareil on sait également et bien que les
différents partiel eux sont maintenus
malgré bien les protestations de
certains étudiants on a pu le voir
encore aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne les biens les
conditions sanitaires qui sont parfois
azul re pas remplies pour pour pour pour
la bonne tenue et surtout les conditions
sécurisées d'examen voilà en tout cas
pour ce petit récapitulatif scolaire en
ce qui concerne ce que l'on a appris ce
soir je vais répéter une dernière fois
avant que nous nous quittons et bien
nous quittions pardon bien en ce qui
concerne donc les restaurants et bars on
sait qu'ils ne seront pas ouverts et que
cela pourra durer au moins jusqu'à la mi
février il faudra donc avoir un peu plus
de nouvelles dans les semaines à venir
en ce qui concerne le monde de la
culture avec les musées les différents
cinémas ou encore le monde du sport avec
les équipements sportifs là aussi pas de
réouverture prévue avant la fin mois de
janvier enfin et bien c'était aussi un
point important pour de nombreux
français qu'ils soient acteurs
économiques ou simples utilisateurs
les stations de ski qui reste donc
ouverte certes mais dont les remontées
mécaniques ne pourront pas être bien
ouverte avant la fin du mois la hausse
il va falloir attendre le 20 janvier un
petit peu avant le début des vacances
d'hiver pour en savoir plus sur bien
c'est cet impact économique qui pourrait
se poursuivre pendant encore plusieurs
semaines
voilà pour en tout cas ces réouvertures
d'établissement en ce qui concerne le
variant à vous le savez ce variant du
virus qui a été détectés au royaume-uni
et bien on sait désormais que 19 cas de
ce variant anglais ont été identifiées
au sein de notre pays et que bien la
fermeture avec des frontières avec le
royaume uni est maintenue jusqu'à nouvel
ordre en ce qui concerne cette évolution
du virus pour le couvre-feu comme vient
de le dire mathieu siro journaliste au
service politique du figaro
on le sait est bien dix départements de
l'est pourrait faire l'objet d'un
couvre-feu avancé à 10 à 18 heures il va
falloir surveiller cela ce qui viendrait
s'ajouter à bien certains départements
qui sont d'ores et déjà d'ores et déjà
dans certains départements qui sont
d'ores et déjà est bien sujet un
couvre-feu à 18 heures enfin en ce qui
concerne les vaccins ce que l'on sait
bien c'est qu'une pré commande de 200
millions de doses de vaccin a été faite
par le gouvernement que jean castex de
colons puissent vacciner un million de
français d'ici à la fin du mois de
janvier et enfin que olivier ferrand le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
affirme que 70 millions de vaccins
seraient livrés avant l'été voilà ce que
nous avons appris ce soir dans les
grandes lignes n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur la page principale du figaro
pour retrouver les différents les
différentes gros informations liées à la
crise sanitaire mais également la
situation internationale
particulièrement active en ce moment
avec on l'a vu cette occupation du
capital aux états unis par des
manifestants pro donald trump
voilà je vais faire un dernier passage
par le chat vous êtes toujours nombreux
à être avec nous justin sauvage vous
demandez comment faire pour poser une
question au prochain point presse aux
différents ministres
notamment en ce qui concerne les
informations qui vous parviennent pour
les universités les examens et bien là
c'est difficile en fait de faire passer
les questions comme cela puisque ça
dépend des journalistes qui sont
présents sur place aux conférences de
presse et du temps qui est allouée aux
différentes questions donc voilà le
meilleur que l'on puisse faire en tout
cas nous au sein de figaro lassé d'être
connecté avec vous et de vous apporter
un maximum d'informations directement
chez vous voilà pour cela merci à tous
d'avoir été avec nous je vais enlever
mon maximum mathilde est parti merci à
tous pardon merci nury dean qui nous
demandait quand les collèges ferme et il
est bien pas pour tout de suite en tout
cas pas de nouvelle information là
dessus merci games of mots à romain
daniélou gym b38 arsouille qui nous
manal stitou vous êtes nombreux en tout
cas ce soir avec nous en ce qui concerne
les écoles de musique que cheikh tongs
lord va pas d'information là-dessus on
n'a pas eu en tout cas de deux points
précis en ce qui concerne les différents
établissements scolaires ou
d'enseignement supérieur ce que l'on
sait juste c'est que et bien si beaucoup
de partiels sont maintenus bien en tout
cas la fermeture on l'a ouvert où la
rouverture de certains établissements
elle n'est pas annoncée n'est pas
précisé par les membres du gouvernement
je vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette
déclaration de jean castex d'olivier
véranda l'espagne aurait lâché et d'une
directrice d pad avec nous sur figaro
life qui a duré un peu plus d'une heure
une heure vingt très précisément je vous
donne rendez vous très vite sur figaro
live pour de nouveaux stream et de
nouvelles déclarations en rapport avec
la crise sanitaire
mais pas que très bonne soirée à tous